our vaginas and penises could well be in
our faces not next to our asses
[Music]
was much of 20th century art right to
view Beauty as a cliche dead end Julian
I'd like to start with you I think
beauty is really important for us and it
is very important for the future of the
world
but the nature of that beauty and what
we mean by it is complicated
and we have to be very clear about it on
the issue on the question I've just been
asked the answer is of course yes and no
Picasso was right I think to create very
beautiful works of art in my opinion in
response to Darwin's discovery of
evolution
he was right to reject the beauty of
appearances before that the Western
Christian world no one else in the world
I want you to remember but the Western
Christian World believed that God had
created the world as it appears and as
you look at God I look at the world you
saw Divinity you saw Beauty what could
be more beautiful
and but Darwin said no uh he proved that
actually the world's changed
dramatically and our vaginas and penises
could well be in our faces not next to
our asses
and Picasso understood that reality and
responded to it that's what was so
amazing about his work and amazing about
Modern Art so modern art was a reaction
against a a concept of beauty that was
no longer truthful
and the uh what happened then
was and beauty is
and beauty is an art is in a response to
to the nature of Truth Nietzsche said uh
we have art to stop us being I think uh
destroyed by truth
and Keats had this wonderful thing of
saying truth is beauty and Beauty truth
that's all you need to know these are
complicated ideas but unless truth
unless beauty is ankle on truth then it
doesn't in my view exist so what
happened in the 20th century was that
our perception of Modern Art is purely a
Western Christian phenomenon Modern Art
was a a response to a changing
understanding of Truth what went wrong
was the idea of progress what was wrong
was the idea of the shock of the new
what what went wrong was duchamp's theft
of Elsa Von freitag's fabulously
beautiful urinal which was the first
great feminist pacifist work of art he
stole it robbed it to his meaning said
it was a piss take against anything
visually creative and he and he's the
foundation for con art and conceptual
art and that whole thing is wrong and it
was an awful mistake and the art world
I'm afraid the museum World in which I
was part of uh has got totally tied into
the Apron Strings of the Art Market and
the investment world of the Art Market
and none of us are now seeing the art
that is really being made today much of
which is very beautiful because it has
no public platform on which it can be
seen this is I'm so angry about it
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas